لقد تحدث شعب هذه الأمة
[موسيقى]
لقد قدموا لنا نصرًا واضحًا ،
نصرًا مقنعًا ، انتصارًا
لنا نحن الشعب
الذي فزنا به بأكبر عدد من الأصوات على الإطلاق
من التذكرة الرئاسية
في تاريخ الأمة 74
مليونًا وأنا  أشعر بالتواضع من الثقة والثقة
التي وضعتها فيّ ، وأتعهد بأن أكون
رئيسًا
يسعى إلى عدم التقسيم ولكن التوحيد
من لا يرى الولايات الحمراء للولايات الزرقاء
يرى الولايات المتحدة فقط.
وقد كرست حياتها
للتعليم ولكن التدريس لا يقتصر فقط على ما
تفعله ،
بل من هي بالنسبة للمعلمين الأمريكيين ،
إنه يوم رائع بالنسبة لك ، كل
ما عليك هو الحصول على واحد خاص بك في
البيت الأبيض
وستقوم جيل بعمل  السيدة الأولى العظيمة ،
أنا فخور جدًا
بها لكل من
تطوعوا
وعملوا في صناديق الاقتراع وسط
هذا الوباء
المسؤولين المحليين المنتخبين ، فأنت تستحقين
شكرًا خاصًا
من الأمة بأسرها ، كل من
صوتوا للرئيس ترامب ، وأنا
أفهم  يفقد  نقطة
الليلة لقد خسرت نفسي عدة مرات ، لكن الآن
دعونا نعطي بعضنا البعض فرصة
حان الوقت للتخلص من الخطاب القاسي
لخفض درجة الحرارة ، ورؤية بعضنا البعض
مرة أخرى ،
والاستماع إلى بعضنا البعض مرة أخرى
ولإحراز تقدم ،
علينا التوقف عن معاملة خصومنا على
أنهم  أعداؤنا
ليسوا أعداءنا ، إنهم
أمريكيون
، إنما هم أمريكيون
، يخبرنا الكتاب المقدس أن كل شيء هناك
موسم وقت لنبني فيه
وقتًا للحصد ووقتًا للزرع
ووقتًا للشفاء ، هذا هو الوقت المناسب
للشفاء في أمريكا.